Масштаби трудової міграції з України
досягли загрозливого рівня для економіки.
Про це написав у Facebook голова Ради Національного банку України
Богдан Данилишин. Так, за даними НБУ,
ще на початку цього року частка мігрантів у населенні
віком від п'ятнадцяти до сімдесяти років становила вісім відсотків.
Торік найбільше українці виїжджали на заробітки
до Польщі, Росії, Італії та Чехії.
До Польщі трудова міграція збільшилась через географічну близькість,
зростання тамтешньої економіки, спрощення правил працевлаштування,
а також через запровадження безвізового режиму з країнами ЄС.
Про це йдеться в інфляційному звіті НБУ.
А от трудова міграції до Росії в останні роки навпаки скоротилась.
Серед причин як політична, так і економічна:
у країнах ЄС можна більше заробити.
Найчастіше українці їздять працювати на сезонні роботи у сільському господарстві,
на будівництво чи ремонтні роботи, а також у сферу послуг,
ресторанний чи готельний бізнес.
Нова хвиля трудової міграції з України, за даними
голови Ради НБУ Богдана Данилишина,
зумовлена багатьма факторами, серед яких
військова агресія Росії проти України,
тривала економічна криза, безробіття.
Рівень безробіття серед економічно активного населення
в першому кварталі цього року склав 9,7 відсотка,
а серед населення працездатного віку - 10 відсотків.
Українські громадяни, які працюють за кордоном,
лише за перше півріччя цього року збільшили обсяги грошових переказів в Україну
на 30 відсотків до чотирьох з половиною мільярдів доларів.
Це неабиякий внесок до ВВП країни.
І, за прогнозами НБУ, ці цифри будуть зростати й надалі.
Разом з тим, відтік працездатного населення уповільнює
економічне зростання країни.
Держава втрачає освічену молодь та кваліфікованих спеціалістів.